[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the
editor-in-chief of the national World
Cities Newspaper group Nancy Fielder and
the Barrister and former government
Minister Anna subri so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
well the Metro has the headline stabbed
in their pushchairs referencing the
attack on four young children at a park
in France
the sun reports that one of the victims
is a three-year-old British girl
that's also the main story for the
express
The Daily Mirror focuses on a woman who
let into the path of the attacker to try
to stop them
the telegraph leads on Ukraine saying
the long-awaited counter-offensive has
begun
the eye describes Britain and the us as
rewriting the special relationship with
the newly agreed Atlantic declaration
but the guardian points out that Rishi
sunak didn't get the free trade deal the
government wanted
the male asks whether NHS patients have
the right to know if the doctors
treating them are transgender
the Ft reports that the financial
conduct Authority is to expand its
investigation into claims of sexual
assault at the hedge fund OD Asset
Management its founder Crispin Odie
denies the claims
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Nancy Fielder and Anna subri welcome to
you both we start with this shocking
story front page of the Metro that the
stabbing of the children and two adults
in France
atrocious Nancy
yeah it's hard to find words isn't it
when stories are just this awful I mean
the footage you've shown every single
image it's a man who calmly walks around
with a huge knife in his hand and
deliberately targets babies their babies
aren't they some of them presumed they
could barely walk they were in push
chairs and they've got serious injuries
they're fighting for their lives now and
I just think how horrific it must have
been for everybody involved you can kind
of see there's one one with a pushchair
and what could you do there is nowhere
to go how do you even defend a baby
against things like that you shouldn't
even have to think about it and it's
such a beautiful place such a
picturesque background and I think it's
rare that we come across I mean there's
a lot of bad news in there out there but
this is absolutely horrific a knife man
who delivered the targets babies when
they're in a playground with no defense
yes I mean it's just truly shocking and
um we saw one woman was seen
um on video desperately desperately
trying to protect her child Anna
exactly
um and you know you take your children
to a playground to have fun and you
think you're going to be safe uh and as
Nancy says Anna see which
um some of your viewers may know it it's
on the route to be for people uh when
they're going on holiday in France
either if they're lucky enough to go
skiing or in the summer or other times
it's a beautiful place and to think of
something as horrific as as this
happening especially in a playground
when you're on holiday absolutely
Dreadful and we can only have our
thoughts and prayers with the families
of those little ones in particular and
the hope that they are not going to be
too seriously injured and they'll all
pull through and be all right yeah so
there definitely will be in our prayers
and the sun pointing to the fact that
that one of the the children is actually
a British girl that was on holiday at
the time Nancy
yeah I mean presumably they've got very
young children you can go on holiday out
of school holidays can't you they've
gone somewhere for you you just never
think that something like this is going
to happen and it must be just to
surrender for the families back home
trying to work out what is going on when
you when you've got
a young child a grandchild over there in
this situation I mean it is I think we
can all picture we can also start to
start to put yourself in that situation
and you just don't know what could you
possibly do there are a few things as
horrific as this and it must be awful
for everybody back home as well as I
mean the whole area must be absolutely
shaking in France yes we spoke earlier
to our correspondent
um who's there for us and and she was
saying that uh well certainly at the
moment police are not
um
saying that it's terrorism related
they're not seeing that as a motive at
the moment Anna
yeah
um look this man apparently is a Syrian
refugee being granted asylum in uh I
think in Sweden in any event he was in
France he's apparently a Christian none
of these things I personally think are
particularly relevant but unfortunately
whenever we have attacks like this which
seem to have absolutely no logic no
motive whatsoever you know wouldn't have
possesses anybody unnecessarily
profoundly mentally Disturbed to do such
a heinous thing or we assume more we
certainly explore that perhaps it's it's
linked to terrorism uh we're told in
this case it's not
yes sir we shall um see obviously it's a
developing story and police still
carrying out investigations
um let's move on to um politics
International politics Nancy and Britain
and the US rewrite those special
relationship these details coming out of
the news conference that Rishi sunak
held with Joe Biden in the States this
evening
yes so there are big smiles big hand
snakes how much has actually been
Rewritten um who knows but both of them
are very very
clear that it's a special relationship
that they've got really good deals here
but actually if you pick through the
detail it's fairly scanned it's
certainly not the incredible
life-changing deal for the country that
was talked about way before the brexit
vote it's a series of
I think one of the papers described in
sort of mini deals and it's good it's a
positive step forward but I think we
could possibly make too much of this
um the most the most powerful thing I
think is them sat together there's the
hand snake there's the smiles
unfortunately Biden says he still likes
us and we've still got a relationship
like no other
Anna what's your thoughts on the
Atlantic declaration
foreign
as as we've heard it looks like it's as
uh I don't think it's even many deals I
think it's just agreements that we'll
work on things like Ai and a lot of the
of the thinking behind this is that we
can cut China out of the supply chains I
I don't have any problem with that
because of our over Reliance uh it's
well there's a really strong base that
we are overly reliant on China uh and
you know they what we all know the
difficulties with China and and there's
also a view that we're also beginning to
reduce the importance of Russia when it
comes to trade so anything that
strengthens our relationship with our
colleague with our friends in America to
me is a good thing but my real takeaway
is as nursing research was saying is to
do with brexit I mean we were promised
that we would get this amazing deal
um with America we were told in fact the
conservatives was in 2019 Manifesto that
we were going to get that deal and I
think that the awful Donald Trump said
that that was possible and those of us
that were opposed to brexit said this is
a load of old nonsense this is just not
going to happen you know you're
basically being lied to and come to you
don't get trade deals with a country
like America like that as we were
punished and I have to say we've been
proved right and yet again we see a
promise that was made about the benefits
of brexit being badly broken but at
least this is a good thing and I think
it's a good thing for our country uh and
it would be even better if we picked up
some of the policies that buying that
about having a strategy that uh on our
industrial strategy or business strategy
that is looking at how we can really get
growth from some of these green
technologies
and Nancy that that's the the point that
the the Guardians making that exact
point that um
soon act didn't get the trade deal that
that he wanted and Asana says that was
promised in in the manifesto
yeah and I mean they put it across as a
very negative thing don't they uh packed
with Biden as hope of trade deal
vanishes it is a great example of how
different stories can be spun depending
on your political inclination as a
newspaper editor
um but yes I mean the the deal is not
big
um but it is a deal and it's positive I
mean there are all sorts of jokes that
actually there's some most senior people
in America can't even remember our prime
minister's name because it's sort of not
in their faces he's not there enough
which is a concern but there is uh we've
got the image we've got these we've got
positive steps forward and it will be
fantastic actually if Biden's serious
that we should be leading the way
instead of supporting
um economics around climate change and
what we can do to sort of
anti-fossil Fuel and technology that
would be fantastic I don't see much of
it happening but I would love it to
happen so that could be a really
positive thing the one question about
the lack of a wider dealer cynic
insisted the Declaration would benefit
British companies and respond to the
particular opportunities and challenges
that we faced right now and into the
Future Let's Take a look before the
break at the the Telegraph and that the
key of counter-offensive has begun at we
read Anna
yes let us hope that this is the
beginning of a huge push Now by Ukraine
to regain their land
following the appalling and unlawful
Invasion by Russia and we know that well
we know that Russia has continued to
commit the most appalling war crimes by
it looks like you know the lot the logic
tells us that they must be responsible
for the blowing up the dam and the
appalling flooding that we are seeing
and here now is uh the the wonderful
zonesky
um in hershon forgive me if I pronounced
that incorrectly and and the emerging
story of course is what the Russians are
now doing having breached the dam and
caused this terrible flooding uh it
seems that they're now actually
um terrorizing bombing people fleeing
from the floods but what the telegraph
is saying and it's there I've splashed
on their front page is that this love
awaited and we hope it to be final
offensive has at last begun and I think
all of us would wish the ukrainians
every success and we must continue to do
everything we can to support them a lot
of their Weaponry has quite properly
been has been supplied to them by
countries like ours and we should all be
really pleased about that and and
congratulate the government for what
it's done let's take a look at the Metro
we're going to go inside the the metro
and this story about um NHS waiting
lists the awaiting list for routine NHS
hospital treatment including knee and
hip operations has hit a record 7.4
million in England this comes months
after Rishi sunaka vowed to cut that
list
Anna
yes
um I was reading this story
um in detail
because it's not just the fact that the
uh waiting lists as the headline says
that 7.4 million people waiting for an
OP
um with this promise from Michigan
really now under real pressure as to
whether or not he's going to be able to
deliver on that when you actually dig
right into that story there's a number
of things that struck me now we we know
from the reports today that cancer
waiting times uh have originally to it
to to a situation which is completely
unacceptable but the other thing that
struck me about this story in the Metro
though is that we've had the busiest
time ever for May in accidental
emergency now we know that there are a
huge winter pressures on the NHS but to
have the the record busiest time in May
is quite extraordinary that that really
needs to Deep dive into it to work out
what Nerf is going on now one of the
factors when it comes to that waiting
list must be the action by doctors and
to uh and also by nurses in the strike
action which we're all familiar with but
in any event these are statistics that
will really cause the government real
concern and of course
who are desperate to have those
operations want those Cancer Treatments
need that speed especially in things
like cancer but also want to want to
know what's going on in a e and why
there are record levels for men of
people going into Ireland
Nancy in the Nash Patel of MacMillan
cancer support is quoted as Saying A
system that cannot cope is letting down
thousands
um its vital government prioritizes
Cancer Care
yes and I think we've all got friends or
family who were suffering from this who
who simply aren't getting the treatment
they need and actually many many who
have died or are dying because they
weren't diagnosed good enough or they
weren't treated enough or their
treatments didn't move a Lot quickly
enough this is a really really enormous
problem and it is a political problem it
needs a political solution it needs the
people who work in our NHS to be treated
correctly to be paid properly to be
respected to be encouraged into the job
because let's be honest not many people
want to do these jobs anymore for
obvious reasons it needs a complete
danger approach but actually the least
interesting thing for the vast majority
of people is the fact that the prime
minister is failing on his targets
because actually if you're waiting one
of the 7.4 million people waiting for an
operation all you care about is that you
need it done or you need it done quickly
and it's a political football that
should never have been allowed to become
football it's far too important the NHS
is the thing that people value most
about this country every single survey
seems to come back and say how much you
love our NHS and yet who is being let
down under 7.4 million people
desperately desperately needing
treatment and not getting it
Anna take us to the guardian and the
picture there of the um Smokey Haze this
is from the wildfires raging in Canada
and at some points during the day you
could hardly see the the sky scene
because of the the depth of the The Fog
and this isn't something that's just
today this has been going on for numbers
of the number of days and he's not
likely to shift for a number of days and
there have been these appalling
wildfires and this is the consequence
and of course it's not just New York I
mean there are pictures obviously of
other places other cities like
Washington so it's I mean look at the
scale of this and I think the thing
that's really concerning people even
more than the fact that it has produced
its extraordinary levels of pollution as
we can see
um in photographs in New York uh
Washington and other places but it's the
fact that those wildfires have come
earlier than they would otherwise have
done and then that adds to this real I
mean it's just no debate about it you
know we are we're basically destroying
our planet you know what more evidence
do people want and we can talk about it
till the cows come home but but actually
we have there's no debate again in my
mind that we have got to start proper
serious action indeed Anna and Nancy
thank you both